[Music]
citizens of the reject Nation it's me
Tera ericon along alongside
Roxy how you doing girl I am so good and
I'm actually really glad that you told
them I'm Roxy because apparently I keep
forgetting to do that and every comment
is like who is this chick this is Roxy
and she's got cool socks on show them
your socks we're going to watch trick or
treat today but it's trick Ur treat okay
and neither of us have watched it and we
are so so ready so you guys don't forget
to leave a like leave a comment and also
ring the
bell ring the bell and don't forget you
can become super sexy super sexy in the
reject Nation if you join patreon cuz
then you can watch our full reaction
along with me and Roxy our full reaction
you guys get it the full reaction with
me and Roxy watching trick or treat okay
if you're on patreon you watch the whole
thing and also read out loud the graphic
will be on screen that's what the script
says Greg and John covers several shows
over there exclusively with the reaction
highlights and watch alongs included I
should really have that part memorized
it's just like a little diddy but I
always just look at the screen and I
went straight for the bold letters and
uh it said read this out loud so I did
women can do everything that men do we
can we really really can we're on the
train we're ready to go do you have any
words before we begin yeah I put the r
in Trick r Treat oh girl I that is that
is got you that's a lot also I found a
pimple patch with hair stuck to the
bottom of my foot when we did that so
just in case you guys were wondering
that's a real trick- or treat treat yeah
all right I think we're ready to
go during the spookiest time of the year
there are a few guidelines all ghosts
and goblins should follow never go to a
stranger's house and never go out
below we almost saw smashing
pumpkins good band good pun rocks makes
me wish every night was Halloween sorry
an you supposed to keep it live why
ancient tradition oh oh
no I know who both these people are damn
I know who she is oh they're going to
kill me at home I can't focus on
anything till I remember who they
are that is some heavy kid breathing she
must be from some TV show I watched
practice no right I think what the
blonde girl is she no that might be WR
no she looks like the girl from lost but
she's not her babe let's just take all
this crap down it looks like a crime
scene she's very famous yeah and then
you're going to play video games until 4
and besides my mom is coming in the
morning she look an aneurysm if she sees
this place really aneurysms are not
funny they are not fun go inside put on
the
tape okay who's this like creepy kid
hate Halloween that's silly Halloween's
the best doesn't seem that way by the
way that house is decorated but is that
not their house no he's obsessed that's
why he's putting on the tape he's cool
no he's really
not
nature she for real clean up the yard
and it's actually Halloween right
now but all the kids are going
home yeah I mean girl you got to wait
till the next day this is
like this
sacr see that dude maybe she only has
one pair of sheets and she needs to wash
them before she goes to sleep she has
six beds she's got to make up so she's
got to rip all these ghosts
down you heard me oh my God he
had oh just a normal dude okay maybe
she's mainly a movie
gal oh okay so what flew up
bat oh I knew it oh my god when she's
like put on the tape I was like it's got
to be
[Applause]
right oh what in
the they ran
away wait she can't be dead though she's
famous although they did it to Drew
barous enough that's like their Scream
moment listen
if he makes that face for too long his
Els are going to get very
deep that was only for the skin care
heads out
there okay
Tunes oh
[__]
oh
oh my God E I don't know if I would have
recognized
her it's in those eyes girl Those Eyes
please give me her name please give me
her name in the beginning of this oh
[Music]
yeah are you more of a trick or more of
a treat kind of gal treat treat all day
man get out of here with those tricks
Melle I'm trying to get Reese's feces
and a p and a pacin
that's no no I said Anna Brian Cox
that's cool too that just said it we're
waiting on Anna Pac we're waiting on
Brian Cox still don't know who that girl
[Music]
was you are not taking care of your
candy buddy that is like nasty
disgusting you should be holding that up
high and like protecting it yeah that's
codyy
blood moon boom something we're using
that comic strip I am not wearing
this keep popping out that's the idea y
yeah it's not really a negative it's
what we do every Halloween Lori whatever
happened to creep God Little Creeper
this little dude you are too young buddy
I remember she's about to be Cinderella
that's my guess I ate some bad
Mexican
ladies there are children out here yeah
and your children's the problem also
what are you guys doing it's like
actually Halloween just getting outfits
now I was right oh you were little
little Disney Princesses Lori come on
out no let got to be her right that
sounds like Anna's
voice oh hey
girl I look like I'm five it's tradition
great what is Trad tradition say we do
now we meet our dates we meet our dates
our dates
or good question we're just in town for
a party tonight and I was wondering what
time you get off work in about 20
minutes actually you know where sheep's
menow is sure so why don't you meet me
there in 45 oh no she's lying they call
them the pretty
Squad oh rude it's like crazy that I
assume that they're Mean Girls Just
because they're pretty yeah it's like
that's not how it works however in
movies it that's how it works she was so
Regina
George that can't be good for your
diabetes
Charlie don't waste a good lie on this
it's just candy guess it's a good thing
I got more I just sit down stay for a
minute why can't I sit down Charlie oh
sit down Charlie tried a little harder
you wouldn't be a virgin at 22 what
excuse me it's practically staple to
your for that girl talking might be the
prettiest person I've ever seen in my
life yeah maybe I'm too oldfashioned but
I've always wanted my first times no
please don't say it special honey listen
we've all been there but you can't
hesitate I'd listen to anything you said
yeah I mean Snow White dang girl that's
some big equipment you've got there
thank you I'm Maria this is Janet and we
have a small problem really we've got
this great party to go to we have no
ride but we don't have any dates oh
right they just talked about
that seemed like they wanted the van
help
yourself it's for the pumpkin not you
promise he looks like the kid in Matilda
that eats the cake oh yeah he does he
also kind of looks like the one of Harry
Potter all these Traditions jack'
lanterns putting on costumes they were
started to protect us but no one really
cares oh no is he
choking uh you poison oh
God
uh that stomach sound I
can't at least you got that tissue in
your
ear there's another
tradition very
important always chck your
candy oh [__]
trick
or oh
no no oh my God I
can't oh he dead or what or is this just
like a projectile vomit pass out that
was very gross I could not eat something
after
that oh
boy
it's kind of shot like a comedy
though we know you're in there what do
you think the guy on the left is an
alien
yeah cost you Mr Wilkins we might be
able to have your jack Lantern it's a
scavenger hunt for Unicef oh yeah
UNICEF uh little boy figuring it out the
Little Pirate his voice is
everything happy
Halloween didn't you get
one go I'll meet you there call me if
you get into trouble you're turning into
mom sisters
yeah why did she stay behind she got to
find a date otherwise it would be like
so embarrassing to have a party you
can't go
stag pre dug grave happy Halloween who
else is in there is there yeah there's
like another body in there right
Daddy I'm back from drink or treating
Billy be quiet watch Charlie Brown and
I'll be in in a minute Charlie Brown's
an
[__] going be some weird Trad yeah
otherwise like his son die or some die
or something cuz what did he say to him
when he was sitting on the steps he was
like check obviously check your
candy there he just throwing body
gross yeah then there's evidence yeah
what an idiot that dog's not going to
eat that whole thing maybe about
that are you finished crapping or what a
who the hell is
[Music]
that I got an N membership in my pocket
Steven Wilkins what in God's name are
you doing down there Wilkins oh it is a
succession Guy what's Brian Cox yeah no
I don't know his name but Brian Cox oh
okay yeah septic tank is acting up is
that what that smell is I'm afraid so
then fix it like a dead out here I
didn't see him is that happy Halloween
screw you
Oh Daddy can I go to the parade with you
later no Daddy has a date how about if
we make some caramel apples but you have
to be
quiet okay oh he's so cute why is
everybody doing everything so late this
is actually Halloween like it's dark out
Daddy I want to go to the
parade Daddy I wish Mommy was still
alive
maybe somebody's taking over his body
like principal and like yeah hates his
[Music]
kid oh was a trick- or treat guy in
there cuz he was like get your kid out
of my yard but it wasn't his kid
Billy the scared me too so can we carve
it now
yeah let's go downstairs what
the bring the
knife that's a lot of masks on the wall
why are they
there usually I'm am all for Gore but I
really don't want to see him kill this
kid right now me neither not in the mood
he's not going to get there right trick
or treat or something is going to come
over and stop him yeah I think he goes
for the pumpkin let's cve a scary face
this time scary face
[Music]
it he went for the kid did he I mean
there's red on the knife there's no way
he he he it's paint okay okay W it
around
but don't forget to help me with the
eyes wait they're talking about a
body oh my God and the
oh they weren't talking about the kid is
in on it they must have been two bodies
that took over their bodies or something
it can't really be the
yeah aren you guys adorable thanks Mrs
Henderson oh my God Mrs Henderson is a
lot yes she's a lot of hot yeah I'm into
it you want to drink or something okay
[Music]
uh is this like an party I'm loving all
the different generations of Halloween
yeah People's Party older people's party
young hot girls party tricker treat
what' you find that's it
sorry but some [__] want up been down
the street smashing all of them but we
have three isn't this enough they're all
up to something nefarious yeah and it's
all the night of Halloween I'm like yeah
that part isn't working for you I it's
really
not is that R she's not an idiot saon
huh it's very alarming hearing the r
word anymore yeah totally did you carve
all these yourself yep made my costume
too like it I do huh me too I'm traitor
Rhonda you say traitor yeah it sounded
like traiter but I feel like it's first
name traitor last name Joe's we'll
probably find out it's just Taylor and
we're
both
oh I'm not mad at
it he's like he needs to clear his blow
his nose or
something she looks oh
[__] what
what
what but what happened is he like a real
life vampire cuz I was like did the
blood just come out of his mouth like
where is her cut she never looked like
she was in pain so yeah
[Music]
exactly
hen Hur again she ain't dead yet wait oh
so we were around time I guess so if I
could turn back
time did she just taste it it's
candy no oh sh I thought she was liing
her lips to be like oh it tastes like
candy it's fake
okay
nope it's the real thing lot of moving
Parts yeah a lot of people there doing
Traditions a lot of people killing
people there's something up with the
pumpkin stuff it's a lot to track you
must really like Halloween you mean sa
also known as all hollow's Eve also
known as h Halloween
Savon celebrated on the one night
between autumn and winter when the
barrier between the living and the dead
was thinnest and often involved rituals
that included Human Sacrifice I love her
me too she's great I like your eye
patch I'm kind of like looking at her
and how she acts I'm like where's she
been why didn't I don't know her well
now you do she's like since then yeah
like since then like I I would have
she's she's she got to have booked
clearly a character yeah yeah you and me
coming at this as actresses like wait
wait but if you're good yeah you should
keep working isn't that the
[Music]
point see this girl is No Angel oh no
why are we here to pair specs to the
dead this is where that school Shut up
Sarah the Halloween school bus Massacre
this Bus full of crazy Jesus will you
shut up and let me tell the damn story
all right this has to do with the other
things too this must come full circle it
happened 30 years ago on a late
Halloween
afternoon that's a cool shot very cool
cool transition a school bus was on its
usual route let me guess it
crashed but this wasn't your typical
school bus and they weren't your typical
kids boogie boogie the hair on the top
of the paper bag is the scariest thing
to me I can't there were eight of them
and they were different troubled
Disturbed
what's up do every day parents put their
dirty secrets on this bus to be driven
to a school miles outside of town 3 2
6 3 2
60 3
[Music]
326 oh 66 oh 66 326 oh is he saying his
address out the driver took a different
route oh and that kid's going to freak
out because if he's counting the houses
and now it changes numbers wrong
way wrong way yeah
uh-oh he drove the bus to an abandoned
rock quarry this rock quarry he killed
him on purpose I
guess likeit
what oh that's really evil yeah like
what didn't know was that over the years
their parents had become exhausted
embarrassed oh my God their parents did
like said said go take him out that's
why it's evil and they were willing to
do anything to ease their burden oh my
God the money they collected together
they asked him to do the
unthinkable this a a last
supper he's going to use it to try to
get
out
use oh oh oh oh oh that was easy I don't
think easy he just slipped right out of
there
ow I
mean
[Music]
oh oh man no no oh good job kid no he's
going to kill them all I know he's going
to drive them off the thing but like
they were probably going to die from the
candy anyway right oh there they go okay
I thought maybe he would like turn it
around
[Music]
maybe uh the driver was never heard from
again as for the bus some say it sank so
deep that it couldn't be found it's
still down there and so are those kids
well little deteriorated yeah shrunk up
pretty good by now eight victims eight
jack' lanterns we're going to leave them
by the side of the lake as an offering
to those who
died cool shot again seemed nice but
there's like some underlying right like
yeah I think there's just got to be some
correlation between that and then the
the father son that we saw like
something's
happen it can only hold three I'll send
the keys back up you guys bring the rest
rude girl you just jealous cuz the witch
girl is better at pumpkin carving than
you and also way nicer feel like she
actually just saved their lives though
not on purpose but
yeah oh to be young and in love oh to be
old and in love like Miss Hendrick what
was her name Miss Henderson is she
Little Red Riding Hood
yeah it doesn't fit with the other girls
no not at
all then again she did doesn't fit with
the other girls no she doesn't and I
don't think she wants to fit let's
go I feel you girl so there's a guy here
who really wants to meet you is he young
uh so he's hideous just get your ass
over here Beggars can't be
choosers he is very cute
yeah sent the cues back up what are the
chances they go down and they're all
dead can't see Jesus what is
that oh God are they going in the water
oh
boy this kid is about to have a panic
attack maybe they're playing a joke on
them or trick yeah and they're like we
just screamed and turned the lights off
that's it traitor Sarah
Shader oh is that a guy's name we
couldn't not traiter Sher
Sher aren't you
coming okay stay here don't let the
candles go out and they'll protect you
okay I love her love her she's the voice
of a four-year-old she really does she
better survive this movie otherwise I'm
going be upset she'll be okay she's a
smart witch so she she's going to figure
it
out a
Kadabra oh didn't go that deep it's
right there bubbles coming from it
[Music]
okay there's never been wind ever here
The Masks stayed right where they were
they're playing a trick on her right I
mean I unless she took off her whole
angel costume and threw some feathers in
there or just placed masks in
there oh my
God that really did [__] scare me
sorry
what also ew oh oh no no what
[Applause]
[Music]
the oh no by not your
glasses oh if you eat this witch I'm
going to be so upset no it's I is it a
trick yeah it's a
trick no they're all going to feel so
bad cuz they were playing a prank you
killed her and they were playing a prank
cuz that's why they tried to get her
there oh I hate them so much I hope they
all die if it was them it is them for
sure oh [__] is she dead was that sher's
voice it was right
okay yes yes yes knock him out I'm glad
she's
okay it was all going so well he was
part of it too Dad Dad you're all dead
Ronda calm down it was all just a a
trick a bad joke I'd say it was a pretty
good one I hate her me too that was so
mean Macy is super she needs therapy
honestly girl you got to get on
betterhelp.com cuz if you think this is
fun I don't know how to help you what
happened to the bus driver I don't know
chip what I didn't say
anything what is that and they broke her
glasses which are so expensive good I
mean I I hope Macy got eaten by the
ghost
kids what is
[Music]
that [__] get
stitches oh
snap R open the gate let us sa please
open the
gate yeah girl you think she does yes or
no I think she probably does right right
cuz she's like at me what are you
doing whatever yall messed up you
deserve it even though Shader tried to
help her you're still in on
[Music]
it that's an awesome
shot
oh all
right they did find really cool locasion
for this like I I think every like area
they're in looks looks really good I'm
not in the mood so just come on out
that's very um ballsy what you just did
yeah
uh my my
what big eyes you
[Music]
have no way right no I mean she's like
it's happening to her right now so it
can't be right oh my
God Lori messed him up oh good I hope so
is this her
oh hey girl hey run to the litter no
more uh-uh I listen to their advice and
played hard to get he bit me at least
you made it sure come here oh what did
you do to him I can't
wait
[Applause]
oh oh it's the
[Music]
principal
oh that's why they all needed dates
they've been killing them all it's a
sacrifice
okay oh did she spite off his oh God why
why would you say that didn't he put his
hand near his thing it's my first time
so just bear with
me does she have to kill him first
[Music]
yeah oh is she a
werewolf
whoa we did see it was a full blood moon
right oh my God yeah oh
man interesting it's a cool transition
weird okay trying to figure out how
everything kind of correlates yeah
that's why they didn't really care who
their dates were
yeah yeah yeah what traditionally
happens when a werewolf bites
you could it be that young girl turned
into Anna pacin the witch yeah I don't
know yeah I don't know how many
timelines we're working with what is
this ghost no this is a wolf which
werewolf is it
oh is that Brian Cox it so it doesn't oh
there we go
[Music]
yeah oh he just has like a mask on the
dog we're an hour in and I don't know
what this movie's about me
[Music]
neither that got me scared me
Steven Wilkins happy
Halloween screw you oh no he lock the
dog out did the dog what are you doing
oh no oh no
okay get the hell out
my
okay
oh was he the one who said help in the
window or was it the other side the
other neighbor he said he was the
yes he was the one saying help
me
oh oh my God if he accidentally shoots
the dog I'm going to be very upset
didn't the last movie we watched didn't
they kill a dog yeah that cuz I just got
Deja Vu hush people that do Horrors love
to pay homage to other horror movies I
hate it don't with the animals y'all do
you think that there is a through line
with all these stories or you think
they're just separate trick-or treat
stories I feel like they might be
separate because at first I thought the
young Macy was like I'm like is she like
the grownup Cinderella and then I got
that out of my head real quick yeah I
was thinking that too but then I'm like
the rest of them don't really match up
that well so I don't know there just has
to be some correlation right yeah I mean
unless it's just the trick- or treat kid
he's always around wherever they but
where does he come from
oh no behind
you what for a treat what is it say give
me something good to eat H I think good
yeah yeah yeah if you don't I don't care
I'll pull down your
underwear that's some Zodiac Killer
writing on the wall right
there
no oh God much about the dog but I do
not like to watch elderly people get
hurt
what are you doing trick or- treat your
kid wait
what oh is it all in his head cuz of
that candy he ate a bite
of you hate to see
it oh he can't turn the knob uh also
where is this kid at he's probably right
there oh my God he's flying what I think
he's on the ceiling I don't
[Music]
[Applause]
know I kind of need a little
backstory
w w help me
W
oh oh man are we going to see oh who who
who
[Music]
oh
whoa told you Smashing
Pumpkins oh no he's
screwed if that thing is made a pumpkin
it's going to regrow itself or something
there's no way it's dead do you care
that we don't know like does it bother
you that we have no idea what that is or
I mean or how it's related to any of the
there has to be like that's going to be
the big turn right oh no it's not
okay oh oh it's okay what did it do stab
him
yeah he's waking It Up watch it's just
like going to all come yeah
oh that's a scary ass like demon the
eyes I
can't the pumpkin Queen
wow yeah that is a scary face to look at
B it
[Music]
up is it just cuz he's like the Scrooge
of Halloween he doesn't give out candy
and this little dude goes around for bad
Halloween
people what I have no idea oh my
goodness maybe just the movie is about
being creepy for the sake of being
creepy yeah that might be it
too oh is that the bus drive he's the
bus driver who's the bus driver Brian
Cox so that's one of the kids that was
on the bus must be and turned into a
demon but how trick or treat
thank you uh he's handing out the worst
candies peppermints and butterscotches
no thank you so this must be the next
year no I feel like this is like right
like directly no cuz his arm I don't
know right now I'm thinking is it
directly after and he goes a few hours
later but you're right he wouldn't be in
these bandages for a year this just like
how you did that fast she's back oh okay
I guess the only like through line is
that everybody goes through their own
[__] on Halloween yeah I guess so the
kid was the one who did all the pumpkins
wait wait not yet and now he changed
that guy into giving out candy and not
being a scrooge but you're supposed to
keep it live it's Halloween not H see
she's doing bad Halloween stuff and
that's why she dies I don't know I feel
like it's more about remember their
parents are the one that killed the kids
like these are the siblings of the
parents they had after them like you
think I don't know
yeah go get her she's a bad Halloween
person these are all the children
yeah that was it oh wait that was it
that was it no what it's a very short
movie oh my God okay
okay okay yeah I guess it's just what
happens on Halloween night but like none
of the rest of them were linked to
the the school crash except for
him
[Music]
okay I mean I want to check who that
blonde girl I just looked at that but I
want to see what she was in that I know
her
[Music]
from that was it
okay well yeah I feel kind of like you
do um okay let's see I
mean lesli Bib and I know her
from oh she's an Iron Man she's oh yeah
she's like a film
girl um she was in God's favorite idiot
which I just watched was not
great yeah she was in tag
she's been a lot she was yeah she's been
a lot of
stuff
League oh the
league
yeah lots of lots of stuff Christine
everheart and Iron Man an Iron Man
2 okay she's an iron heart girl all
right
well okay I still I want to know what
happened to the witch girl
I like she leaves the kids down there
they well deserve we just saw her walk I
know but I'm like I want the rest of the
story with like the girls who are
vampires and they get their days to kill
them in the forest and then she leaves
the kids down there to die well good for
you because you know what they were not
good to you and I guarantee you you're
going to have concussion when you go
home you'll figure it out don't go to
sleep tonight next is just like the Rand
like the girl that I'm like oh the
trick-or-treater it makes sense it
Scrooge he sets up his yard right he's
like he gives him pumpkins and he goes
to kill him but he gets a piece of candy
and he he turns his mind around I guess
to giving out candy during Halloween but
like is he going to change the mind of
the girl that he the blonde girl we were
just discussing he kills her cuz she's a
bad Halloween lady you've made that
whole Theory up which is she she's a bad
Halloween lady he doesn't kill he
doesn't kill I just don't I don't I mean
I liked it was entertained but also what
happened the principal and why was the
principal and the kid killing killing
people digging the heads out why cuz a
trick-or-treat guy right or like what
like okay wait okay pause rewind yeah
okay pause why was the principal and the
kid killing like because it was
afterwards so here are my thoughts this
is what I got for you give it give it I
wish that you and I had paid more
attention to the validity of the comic
book nature of this because this was not
really it is a feature obviously but
this was not really like the the what
you and I are used to in a threea
structure like with the story with the
through line I think that this movie
tried to tell us we are telling a lot of
vignettes and and the whole arching
theme is that this is taking place on
Halloween night but here are different
things going on in this town in Ohio
this weird ass witchy town There's this
there's this uh bus crash that happened
there's these um werewolves that exist
there's this trick-or treat little boy
that comes for people like there's all
these things that happen in this town
they all just separate and they're
separate and they have nothing to having
to do with each other in my mind because
how we've been trained to watch movies
not necessarily TV shows as much but
movies is I was just waiting for it all
to click yeah and because of that I feel
like I enjoyed myself less like before
we started this Greg had said he watches
this every year I actually can see that
more right like now that we know what it
is now we know what it is putting it on
would be kind of fun because there's a
lot of different fun stories and
elements but I was I was very for lack
of better words and I know this is going
to upset people at home but I was very
disappointed in this storytelling
because I was hoping that this was
something that it wasn't which was a
cohesive colle like one big like bait
and switch at the end you're like oh
right but they did do a good job telling
us like there was all the comic book
strip stuffs and the later and the
whatever like I think he was telling us
you know these are different um issues
almost and they're all but all taking
place on this one night and that is the
through line yeah but I really I wish I
had known more about this movie going
into this movie because I think I could
have had a better time but because I
didn't
I wow yeah so did disappointed really
yeah I mean I really I enjoyed it like
while we were watching it each and every
story I was also trying to go like well
then why does the principal end up with
the werewolves like and why was he
biting girls before like why is he just
a straightup murderer but now I'm like
okay fine separate comic book he's just
a crazy murderer also principal his son
is in on it they kill people and I don't
think so like but what's the other you
know the body do you think that he was
burying these bodies before he got eaten
by a
wolf see no no yes because the kid goes
are we can I go to the parade with you
later and he's like no we got to we got
to carve him up so they carve him up he
goes to the parade that's when he bites
that one girl she's dead and then he
ends up with the werewolves at the end
but why is he biting the one girl
exactly see this is where this is where
it got a little bit like but why is he
there please explain it to me you know
what I wish is that there was a trick-or
treat too where they were like listen
we're going to bring it all together for
you but I do I did I did really enjoy
myself like each one there was a Twist
like I didn't see some of this stuff
coming like at all I didn't I wouldn't
have guessed a lot of twists in here
which made it extra fun and I really
enjoyed how the witch left the kids
behind because they were jerks I was
you know what's interesting is that
we're watching the trailer on repe right
now and it just said plays out kind of
like Pulp Fiction and I see what they're
me what they mean in terms of like it
just like the vibe of it well just this
everything being so sectioned and
compartmentalized what's wrong great you
you totally forgot how to have fun Roxy
that's what this all comes down to in in
the doorway I think you set me up for
failure on this one all I said was I
watch it every Halloween yeah can
everyone hear Greg he said also with an
get a fist fight all I said is I watch
it every it's about to be a bloodfest oh
bloodfest in the comments you mean no
just between you and I oh no end in the
comments because I know this movie is so
loved we can even see like on IMDb it's
got a four and a half out of five stars
or 22,000 people voting like or rating
it it's it's not that I don't see that
there's Merit to this and again I think
I'd like it better on the second time
third time fourth time but like as a as
a sto as a Storyteller I like a story
this isn't really a story it was like
it's many it's like many St yeah yeah
and I I mean I I still like I I do like
especially when the trick-or treat kid
was revealed holy junk that like that
whole look what was that I don't know
it's a kid it's a
kid no I don't I don't I don't think so
I think it might be separate I think it
might be separate the kids from the
crash see I feel but also wait when the
witch leaves those kids down there and
she gets up she leaves trick-or treat is
there and she just kind of like nods to
him and he's who are you calling
trick-or treat trick or kid the one with
the head that yeah the one with the bag
is that what he's named or you're I have
no I'm just calling him trick or- treat
because I'm like oh it's the the trick
or every time I've seen trick-or treat
it's that head on a poster in my brain
okay so he was there at the site when
she comes up from the elevator she's
carrying her thing he was just around so
I'm like maybe is he is he part of I
don't know like bro he was an alien I
know but I'm like but why was he at that
crash site too he was just everywhere I
don't know cuz he was an alien I feel
like this what this showed us was
vampires werewolves
aliens like legit like serial murders
they just all the supernatural stuff
yeah why did homie go upstairs to watch
porn and then pass
out yeah interesting that's like that's
like one of those Halloween trops you're
like I just put it we put it in here and
it's kind of funny like when you
actually think about everything that
happens in this movie you're like this
is every a little bit of every Halloween
Trope all mixed into one one mixed bag
of candy and that makes trick-or treat I
can feel that I'm going to get
annihilated but I can't lie about how I
feel never have I ever felt worse for
not loving a movie because I feel like
this is a lot of people's favorite
Halloween time movie and it was there
was really fun aspects of it like
moments where we were like ooh jump
scares and stuff that is fun for sure
yeah and know if they were like little
shorts I don't know I
just I'd watch it again I'd watch it a
third time I'd put it on in the
background totally but I really wish
somebody sat me down beforehand and
warned you and was like don't try to
connect the pieces there is no
connection there is no there's no
connection yeah I mean I'm just glad I
can go to halloweent town and now buy
one of those suckers or get one a thing
that looks like the trick-or treat
because now I've watched it because I am
they have cool stuff for trick-or treat
there and I was like no I've never
watched it can't get it because I'm not
am I going to do buy stuff from a movie
I haven't seen now I've seen it yeah
that's true you can't do that can't do
that I won't no no no no
um okay I'm I'm G to rate it because I
did have a lot of fun I I'll put it at
like a seven and a half out of 10 out of
out of 10 I think I'm going to do that
cuz I was I was really truly I mean
you're trying to appease them or you're
not you really liked it that not not
really I did once she started bringing
up the through line like how do you
think it all connects I'm sorry I messed
it up for you my only no no not mess it
up I started thinking yeah how does it
the only thing that bugged me is that it
the ending was so just like what that's
it uh that I wish it was longer and
maybe they had a little bit of a of a
through line at the end but for the
whole time of me watching it I did I did
really enjoy it it moves fast like time
flew by for me only and it might just be
because there's 17 plots in this and
it's only an hour and 22 minutes yeah so
short I I don't know I mean every little
story and there was a switch with like
the the werewolves I didn't see that
coming it was weird yeah that was my
favorite story that was cool right the
girls were bitching like I really like
that story line I would have loved a a
90 minute that that and then to see that
turn and then what happens next like
even just that I loved that part yeah I
also really like the switch of like the
dad and the kid go down and they're like
let's go carving and the kid just like
cannot wait to carve up ahead like what
I would like to see that story I don't
know like follow it a little bit because
Dad's got bodies in the backyard he's
hiding he keeps the heads in there so
you guys can carve what else is going on
there and also he's a principal yeah I
mean good movies do leave you wanting
more but I want so much more so much
like yeah I think that even us assuming
based on that one photograph that the
Brian Cox is the bus driver yeah that
was crazy too I want more of that um
like what happened there what was the
backstory of the parents like all of
these I would have loved their whole
movie yeah I agree I should have also
maybe made the link already I kept
talking about Brian Cox's scars and they
made it very clear that when the bus
driver climbs out he has all the
scratches on his face that I guess I
could have gotten there but I didn't
until he was like burning those pictures
but then that one did have correlation
so that's interesting that none of the
other ones and maybe you know I'm
probably going to watch fan theories on
this and maybe there's some crazy
theories that make this more fun for me
even because there may might be a
connection through everything that
people have kind of
yeah figured out um wow you seven and a
half that is very high for this for
me I just feel like I would I was I my
thing about a movie when I'm like rating
it lower is if I get like really bored
and in this luckily I wasn't I was
engaged and I did think there was a lot
of fun stuff it did Keep Me guessing and
I got a couple of good jump scares in
that which I enjoyed um I'm with you I
was never bored either did good job keep
entertained I it's lacking so much story
for me and structure in the through line
yeah yeah yeah yeah and character
development like and I know it's a fun
horror movie and that's like maybe not
how some people are watching and again
like if they were doing this at um
Hollywood Forever Cemetery I would go
cuz what a fun one to watch not fully
paying attention you're eating yourself
you're out of the grave site whatever
that kind of stuff this would be great I
understand why it got
why people love it the way they do upon
repeat watching right but for me on
First Watch it's like a four yeah all
right that's a four it's a big
difference it's not fair not call it
five because five would be average right
so it's I'm not saying this movie is a
stinker it's super not so maybe five
five she's going to go with five I'll
stick with
7.5 I don't think there's another one of
these but I would well I would love it
if there was a trick-or treat too where
they were like let's show you the these
stories I just want to follow the witch
girl I love her I want to know what
happens to her um I don't know any any
last thoughts Rock just looking at how
this describes itself on the night when
demons and tortured souls are free to
walk the earth alongside mortal
revealers revelers uh four Tales of
Terror will make you laugh even while
scaring you oh see we should have Tales
tal of Terror I really wish I had paage
that's on me that I really wasn't they
were giving us signs about the comic
book and Tales of Tera I even said that
out loud like these were separate Tales
if this was titled four Tales of Tara
Roxy would have been like eight out of
10 honestly maybe she would have been
like I'm there and now I get it and
we're not those Tails I wish were there
was still if they weren't connected at
all I wish we did get more it is it is
it is a little bit of a throw off
because the trick-or treat kid is like
he was land he was everywhere in the
background where I was like wait is he
the connector and why is he there
watching the the vampire the principal
vampire guy killed the girl he was there
at the parade and then he was there when
the witch came out and then he's killing
people at houses um I mean and you keep
calling him he but that alien was maybe
he's a girl oh yeah I mean it was very F
alien you're right you're right also I
think when she uh was making noise it
did sound like a girl
like I don't know I don't I'm a girl and
I can't even I can't do it so I want to
know if you guys know where I'm coming
from are you guys just like know that's
crazy Roxy it's great or you like we get
what you mean watch it again let me know
right let her know uh in a nice way let
me know let her know you guys got to be
cool nice kind I tell you that mostly
every time only treats no tricks no no
tricks only treats we love you guys let
us know what we should watch next we're
into the spooky season we're ready we're
going for it uh I think that's it trick
trick or treat man trick or Tri oh that
was yeah you're supposed to look at that
you're supposed to look I didn't move
and then you still missed
it it's bad you're supposed to look at
the elbow I don't I look at the hand cuz
that's just how I rock and roll okay we
love you guys and we will see you on the
next one
bye uh oh
[Music]
Greg your last
video